they gathered for a second day with the
chair they need to fill still empty the
engine room of the American Democratic
machine is rudderless unable to choose
its leader Madam clerk I Rise to
nominate Hakeem Jeffries as Speaker of
the House Kevin McCarthy for Speaker of
the House Byron Donalds for Speaker of
the House of Representatives
to find a mess comparable to this you'd
need to go back a century it's all about
this man Kevin McCarthy the Republican
leader of a house that now has a
republican majority so he should be the
speaker but beyond the backpacks it
hasn't quite gone to plan the gentleman
is recognized for a second day his
allies nominated him
but again he fell short of the votes
it's only week one of the Year an
American political drama is in full
swing this is about more than just the
messy mechanics of democracy because it
is exposing the deep deep divisions
within just one party the Republican
party's majority is so narrow that they
can't even get this legislative session
open until they literally get their
house in order American democracy is
stalled with a fourth vote against him
by lunchtime the smiles for the cameras
he knows are on him mask the
embarrassment
Jeffries Moore voted for the minority
Democratic leader that voted for him on
the other side of the chamber the
Republican Rebels plotted their next
move and yet the man they'd naturally
follow Donald Trump is backing the man
they won't McCarthy even his caps locked
command hasn't pulled them into line
among the rebels Congressman Bob good
we're going to resolve this in a few
hours or a few days or even a couple of
weeks but we will live with this
decision for two years before the next
election and folks aren't going to be
voting in the next election based on how
long it took for us to choose a speaker
down Pennsylvania Avenue at the White
House a president aware of the look it's
not a good thing because the United
States of America and I hope they get
their act together
we are learning plenty through all this
yes American politics is in An Almighty
mess and yes the power of trump it does
seem to be waning but beyond all that
one of the two parties dominating
politics here is so fractured it's
paralyzing the political process the
speaker's chair still empty Mark Stone
Sky News in Washington